let's say I have the subspace V V and
this is a subspace and we learned all
about subspaces in the last video and
it's equal to the span of some set of
vectors and I showed in that video that
the span of any set of vectors is a
valid subspace so this is going to be
it's going to be the span of v1 v2 all
the way so it's going to be n vectors so
each of these are vectors now let me
also say that all of these vectors are
linearly independent are linearly
independent so v1 v2 all the way to VN
this set of vectors are linearly
independent linearly independent
now before I kind of give you the
punchline let's review what exactly span
meant span meant that this set this
subspace is represents all of the
possible linear combinations of all of
these all of these vectors so you know I
could have all of the combinations for
all of the different seas so c1 times v1
plus c2 times v2 all the way to CN times
VN for all of the possible for all the
possible seas in the real numbers you
take all the possibilities of these and
you put all of those vectors into a set
that is the span and that's what we're
defining the subspace V as now the
definition of linear independence meant
that the only solution to c1 v1 plus c2
v2 plus all the way to CN VN that the
only solution to this equaling the zero
vector maybe I should put a little
vector sign up there is when all of
these terms are equal to zero c1 is
equal to c2 is equal to all of these CN
is all all of them are equal to 0 or
kind of a more a common-sense way to
think of it is that you can't represent
any one of these vectors as a
combination of the other vectors now if
both of these conditions are true that
this set of vector the span of the set
of vectors is equal to this subspace or
creates this subspace or it spans this
subspace and that all of these vectors
are linearly independent then we can say
that the set of vectors we can call
maybe we call this we could call the set
of vectors s where let me say s is equal
to v1 v2 all the way to VN it's equal to
that set of vectors we can then say and
this is the punchline we can then say
that s the set s is a basis a basis for
V and this is the definition I wanted to
make if something is a basis for a a set
that means that those vectors if you
take the span of those vectors you can
construct you can get you can get to any
of the vectors in that subspace and that
those vectors are linearly independent
so the linear so there's a couple of
ways to think about it one is there's a
lot of things that might span for
something for example if this spans for
V then so would let me add another
vector let me let me define another set
let me define set T to be all of set s
v1 v2 all the way to VN but it also
contains this other vector I'm going to
call it the V no no let me call it the V
special vector so it's going to be
essentially the set s plus 1 more vector
where this vector I'm just saying is
equal to v1 plus v2 so clearly this is
not a linearly independent set but if I
asked you what the span of if I asked
you what the span of T is the span of T
is still going to be this subspace is
still going to be this subspace V but I
have this extra vector in here that made
it nonlinear nonlinearly independent
this set is not linearly independent so
this is linearly so T is linearly
dependent so in this case T
is not a basis basis for V and I'd
showed you this example because the way
my head thinks about basis is the basis
is really the the minimum set of vectors
that I need the minimum set and I'll
write this down this isn't a formal
definition but I view a basis let me
switch colors as really the let me get a
good color here as a basis is the
minimum the minimum I'll put it in
quotes because I haven't defined that
the minimum set of vectors of vectors
that spans that spans the space that
it's a basis of spans the subspace so in
this case this is the minimum set of
vectors and I'm not going to I'm not
going to prove it just yet but you can
see that look this one this set of
vectors right here it dis span the
subspace but it's clearing up the
minimum set of vectors because the span
of this thing I could still remove this
last vector here I could still remove
that guy and still and then the span and
the span of what's left over is still
going to get me to my subspace is still
going to get to it's still going to span
my subspace V so this guy right here was
redundant and a basis in a basis you
have no redundancy each one of these
guys is needed to be able to form to be
able to construct any of the vectors in
the Subspace V let me do some examples
let me do some examples so let's just
take let's just take some vectors here
let's say I have let's say I define my
set of vectors and I'll deal in r2 so
let's say I have the vector 2 + 2 3 and
I have the other vector let's say I have
the other vector 7 0 so first of all
let's just think about the span the span
of the set of vectors this is a set of
vectors so what's the span
of s what's all of the linear
combinations of this well let's see if
it's all of our two so if it's all of
our two that means the linear
combination of this could be could be
all we could always construct anything
in r2 with a linear combination of this
so if we have c1 times 2/3 plus c2 times
seven zero if it is true that this fans
all of our two then we should be able to
construct we should always be able to
find a c1 and a c2 to construct any
point in r2 and let's see if we can show
that so we get to c1 plus seven c2 is
equal to x1 and then we get 3 c1 3 c1
plus 0 C 2 plus 0 is equal to x2 and if
we take this second equation and divide
both sides by 3 we get c1 is equal to X
2 over 3 and then if we substitute that
back into this first equation we get 2/3
2/3 I'm just substituting c1 in there so
2/3 X 2 right 2 times X 2 over 3 is 2/3
X 2 plus 7 c2 is equal to X 1 and then
what can we do we can subtract the 2/3 X
2 from both sides let me do it right
here so we get 7 c2 is equal to x1 minus
2/3 X 2 divide both sides of this by 7
and you get c2
let me do it in yellow you get c2 is
equal to x1 over 7 minus 2 over 21 x2 so
if you give me any X 1 and any x2 where
either of you know x1 or x2 are a member
of the real numbers we're talking about
about our revolver everything we're
going to be dealing with right now is
real numbers you give me any two real
numbers I just put them into I take my X
2/3 and I'll give you your c1 and you I
take the x1 divided by 7 and subtract
221st times your x2 and I'll get you
your c2 this will never break there's no
division by
any of these so you'll have to worry
about these equal to zero these two
formulas will always work so you give me
any X 1 and any X 2 I can always find
you a c1 or c2 which is essentially
finding a linear combination that will
equal your vector so the span of s is r2
the span of s is equal to r2 now the
second question is is are these two
vectors linearly independent
are they linearly independent and linear
independence means that the only
solution to the equation C let me switch
colors the only solution to the equation
C 1 times the first vector plus C 2
times the second vector equaling the
zero vector that the only solution to
this is when both of these equal zero so
let's see if that's true we've already
solved for it so if X 1 in this case X 1
is equal to 0 and X 2 is equal to 0
right this is just a special case where
I'm making them equal to 0 vector if
they're 1 if I want to get the zero
vector
C 1 is equal to 0 over 3 so C 1 must be
equal to 0 and C 2 is equal to 0 over 7
minus 220 first times 0 so C 2 must also
be equal to 0 so the only solution to
this was setting both of these guys
equal to 0 so these two vectors so s is
also s is also a linearly independent
set linearly independent so it's fans
are two it's linearly independent so we
can say definitively that s the set s
the set of vectors s is a basis is a
basis for r2 now is this the only basis
for r2 well I could draw a trivial
trivially simple vector set of vectors I
could do this one let me call it let me
call it T if I define T to be the set
one zero
and zero one does this span r2 can I you
know let's say I want to I want to
generate the I want to get to X 1 and X
2 how can i construct that out of these
two vectors well if I always just do X 1
times 1 0 plus X 2 times 0 1 that'll
always give me X 1 X 2 so this
definitely does span r2 so it definitely
does span r2 is it linearly independent
well I could show it to you know if if
you wanted to make this equal to the 0
vector so if you want to make this equal
to the 0 vector if this is a 0 and this
is 0 then this has to be a 0 and this
has to be a 0 and that's kind of obvious
there's no way that you could get one of
the other vectors by some multiple of
the other one there's no way you could
get a 1 here by multiplying this by
anything and vice versa so it's also
linearly independent linearly
independent and the whole reason why I
showed you this is because I wanted to
show you that look this set T spans r2
it's also linearly independent so T is
also a basis so T also a basis for r2
and I wanted to show you this to show
that if I if I look at a vector subspace
and r2 is a valid subspace of itself you
can you can verify that but if I have a
subspace it doesn't have just one basis
it could have multiple bases in fact it
normally has infinite bases so in this
case s is a valid basis and T is also a
valid basis for r2 and actually just so
you know what T is the situation here
this is called a standard basis and this
is this is the standard standard basis
and this is what you're used to dealing
with in just you know regular calculus
or physics class and if you remember
from physics class this is the unit
vector this is a unit vector I and then
this is the unit vector J and it's the
standard basis for two-dimensional
Cartesian coordinates
and what's useful what's useful about a
basis is that you can always and it's
not just drove the standard basis is
that you can represent any vector any
vector in your subspace you can
represent any vector in your subspace by
some unique combination of the vectors
in your basis so let me show you that so
let's say that the set let's say the set
v1 v2 all the way to VN let's say that
this is say a basis for for I don't know
just you know some some subspace u so
this is a subspace subspace u so that
means that these guys are linearly
independent and also means that the span
of these guys or all of the linear
combinations of these vectors will get
you all of the vectors all the possible
components all of the different members
of U now what I want to show you is each
member of you can only be uniquely
defined by a unique set of kind of a
unique combination of these guys let me
be clear about that let's say that a
let's say my vector a is a member of our
subspace u that means that that a can be
represented by some linear combination
of these guys right these guys ban u so
that means that we can represent our
vector a as being c1 times v1 plus c2
times v2 these are vectors all the way
to CN times VN right now I want to show
you that this is a unique combination
let's and to show that I'm going to
prove I'm going to prove let's I'm going
to proof by contradiction let's say that
there's another combination let's say I
can also represent a by some other
combination d1 times v1 plus d2 times v2
plus all the way to DN times VN right
now what happens if I subtract a from a
I'm going to get the zero vector let me
subtract these two things if I subtract
a from a a
- a is clearly the zero vector it's
clearly the zero vector and if I
subtract this side from that side what
do we get we get hold it in a different
color we get C 1 minus D 1 times V 1
plus C 2 minus D 2 times v2 all the way
to my I'm at the point on my board where
it starts to malfunction all the way to
C you don't you can't see it CN minus V
n it's showing up so on CN minus V CN
minus it's messing me up let me rewrite
it on the left right here where it's
less likely to mess up the zero vector
and the zero vector I'll write it like
that is equal to C 1 minus D 1 times V 1
plus all the way all the way up to CN
minus DN times V n right I just
subtracted the vector from by itself now
I told you that these are a basis
there's two things that meet when you
say a basis it says that these guys the
span of these guys makes this subspace
or the span of these guys is this
subspace and also tells you that these
guys are linearly independent so if
they're linearly independent the only
solution to this equation right this is
just a constant times V 1 plus another
constant times v2 all the way to a
constant times VN the only solution to
this equation is if each of these
constants equals 0 so all of those
constants have to be equal to 0 over
here before it messed up this has to
equal 0 this Ackles equals 0 that was a
definition of linear independence and we
know that this is a linearly independent
set so if all of those constants are
equal to 0 then we know that C 1 if this
is equal to 0 then C 1 is equal to D 1 C
2 is equal to D 2 all the way to C n is
equal to D n so by the fact that it's
linearly independent all of these each
of these constants have to be equal to
each other and that's our contradiction
I assume they're different but the
linear independence force them to be the
same
if you have a basis for some subspace
any member of that subspace can be
uniquely determined by a unique
combination of those vectors and just to
hit the point home I told you I told you
that this was a basis for r2 and my next
question is and I just want to kind of
backtrack a bad if I just added another
vector here if I just added the vector 1
0 is now is s now a basis for r2 well no
it clearly will continue to span r2 but
this guy is redundant this guy is in r2
this guy is in r2 and I already told you
that that these two guys Alone's fan r2
that anything in r2 can be represented
by a linear combination of these two
guys this guy is clearly in r2 so he can
be represented by a linear combination
of these two guys so therefore this is
not a linearly independent set this is
linearly dependent linearly dependent
and because it's linearly dependent I
have redundant information here and then
this would no longer be a basis so in
order for these to be a basis I kind of
have to create the minimum set of
vectors that can span or the most
efficient set of vectors that can span
in this case r2